to give these introductory words to
introduce to you very briefly what
interact is and why we're here it's a
somewhat unusual organization or
consortium that we're doing here
it's a network of top universities who
want to collaborate and prepare for a
globalized future universities are by
their definition and by their very
nature typically local and they are
typically regional they get funded by
regional money they are located at a
regional in a regional area and they
teach local students traditionally now
the world is changing we have spent the
afternoon discussing how globalization
and technologies really affect the way
we teach and the way universities will
operate in the future interact is a
network of universities so it's not
export of education is its universities
that consider themselves top in the
world in different regions of the world
who collaborate and work together to do
student exchanges to do joint research
projects to have mutual faculty exchange
to do summer schools to do distinguished
lectures and thereby really have a very
active exchange between the best of the
world in in the in the major regions of
the world so as you see our panel that
we have brought together our
representatives it's the first time we
have such a lucky constellation of
getting the presidents of such top
universities to come together in one
place and actually discuss what this
future would look like so we have of
course Carnegie Mellon University and
University of Southern California
represented Karlsruhe Institute of
Technology Italian Institute of
Technology Waseda University in Japan n
ICT in Japan and Hong Kong University of
Science and Technology you see the three
main parts of the world represented and
discussing here this afternoon this
future we have also external members who
will act as respondents
all very illustrious and famous people
from industry and academia Panasonic
represented Nokia Research Centre
Deutsche Telekom Stanford University and
X Amazon TV I insisted on I will not
moderate
I wanted to just briefly introduce you
why we're here what interact is what
we're trying to do and what we were
trying to do this afternoon and we had a
very exciting discussion which we will
expand on in this panel this evening at
Frank is a good friend of mine and a it
turns out we studied both at Carnegie
Mellon University get our PhDs more or
less the same time our past when went in
all kinds of wild different directions
but here we are together again and his
vice-president at Apple he obviously has
a very distinguished career and in
industry and he also serves on the board
of trustees of Carnegie Mellon he will
be moderating this panel so here's what
we're gonna do tonight
in the next 45 minutes or so we're gonna
go through a series of questions that
I'm going to ask of various
distinguished members of the panel here
and hopefully we'll get some time for
questions from the audience
and we'll see how this goes so the first
question to the university presidents is
what are your current efforts to prepare
for globalization I'll let dr. Cohen
answer because I know he I just do that
a board meeting and I know he knows the
answer to this that's right I can't keep
it to 45 minutes though okay what I'd be
very brief Carnegie Mellon in the last
decade I'm president of Carnegie Mellon
University Carnegie Mellon in the last
decade he's become much more global than
it ever was before we are striving to
become a global University even though
we don't know what that is but when we
get there I guess we'll discover it
we're so committed to this for two
reasons one is the world into which our
current students will graduate is
already very highly connected it's a
global economy they have to know how to
work across cultures and be comfortable
moving from one culture to another
therefore we think our university should
be global in its composition and what it
does
second of all we believe that for the
future of Carnegie Mellon University we
need to be where the growth in economies
and influence is taking place so we have
acted on those two things today 30% of
our students in Pittsburgh are
international students foreign passport
caring that's among the highest
percentages of any university in America
the content that what they learn is much
more global than it ever was before
by design on the second part of this the
second reason we're so committed to
becoming global we now have campuses
here we think this is our first
international campus careful
you can interpret that any way you want
here in Doha Qatar and Middle East and
in Adelaide Australia with major
programs but now campuses in Portugal
Taiwan Korea Singapore and we're working
on Rwanda and India watch this space
that's what we're doing to deal with
globalization so dr. Wu you've been both
in the US and in Hong Kong how about the
your efforts at globalization I I think
the main effort at globalization has
been to found a university over in Hong
Kong we are less than 20 years old about
18 years and ranked extremely highly I
think in all the fields that we actually
cover which are science technology and
business primarily all of the faculty
90% of the faculty came from North
America that's 500 faculty about 55%
from the top 20 universities if we
include Oxford and Cambridge as North
America
it is a 100% English language University
in a region which is obviously
overwhelmingly Chinese speaking the
internationalization efforts on our
student body have exploded we have not
only 12% of the undergraduate students
coming from the mainland of China but we
have also an exploding body of European
and American students not just exchange
but full-time now we have been very
welcoming of programs such as interact
and other international collaborations I
see some faces here and I believe that
this is the healthiest way to go forward
in terms of globalization we are playing
a unique role in Greater China insofar
as we are a very American University we
are the only very American University in
the region and yet we have very very
strong ties to our colleagues in both
the mainland of China as well as of
course our roots in the West and we hope
that through programs such as interact
will be able to continue playing that
sort of a bridge which will lower the
barriers across the entire globe thank
you dr. Santini how about a European
perspective yes I'm not a president by
the way we'll make you a president will
make you a president for tonight so I
mean what we are doing I teach a
relatively young institutions so what we
did i disturb it IIT is just five years
old what we did at the start we try to
get a sort of cultural globalization in
the sense of establishing an institute
which is a strongly multidisciplinary it
is working on humanoid technologies but
it is also working on
you know science and material science
and so we are prepared for the change of
we are trying to prepare ourself for the
changes that we see in front of us
in terms of science in terms of research
which is going to put is putting humans
in the center of the researcher elena
more than than in the past so this was a
sort of a general attempt to you know to
globalize what we are doing and more
specifically what we are investing a lot
is on research tools which can be shared
by as many people as many researchers or
students as possible working with robots
it is really very hard to have inter
international groups working on together
because the platforms are different so
we are really investing a lot on a
project working on open software and
open hardware our was the first the iCub
project that we have was the first open
robotics project and is now involving
more than 20 institutions in European
and one in the United States so in order
to prepare for globalization you need to
be prepared to to have an open mind in
terms of in terms of community
scientific community and also to have
the open tools for scientific research
Thanks thank you dr. shred you have any
comments you'd like to make yes also the
case of a said the most important issue
is the globalization we have now about
once 4,000 foreign students in campus
that the only
I'm about 10% not but we are sending our
students to outside maybe this year 1000
that maybe half of the students 500
maybe staying in United States around
here in California several hundred
confessing then student exchange and the
faculty exchange that's a very important
one and the second maybe we must cherish
with our research university we should
cooperate to the more global fundamental
issues of sustainability over
survivability were accept and such a
collaboration is important and necessary
in that sense the kind of this
collaboration in the field of robotics
and language processing may be they
involved cultural difference programs we
are making some also we can provide and
then the interact project is very much
interest interesting and important that
we seek thank you
so dr. hall what you need to know is my
actually my younger daughter went to USC
and on the other hand I was an undergrad
at Stanford and I was very happy to see
us beat you in football so given all of
that perhaps you want to talk about
globalization
so I actually grew up in Palo Alto so I
guess I'm feisty there you go thank you
as well and I was born in California and
being born here and lived here all of my
life almost all my life I've seen a lot
of change and during that period this
state really has become like a nation
under on to its own and it's
international
so California is a place that has been a
magnet for the best and the brightest
from around the world they come here
because of the innovation they come here
because of the weather too but this is
really a vibrant place to be at USC we
have more international students than
any other university in the country with
more than 7,000 students and I like to
believe they come here because of the
great university and the experience they
have there and I think that is part of
it but it's also the culture we offer
here in this state where a student can
come from India China Indonesia almost
any country in the world we have 125
countries represented at the University
and really feel at home both within
their own culture and within a blending
of cultures our university strategy is
partly on creating that home for
international students from around the
world it's also based on giving
experiences for our own students to
travel elsewhere so that most of our
undergraduates many of our graduate
students will have an experience abroad
to experience the cultures and then also
from a research perspective creating
selective collaborations particularly in
the Pacific Rim countries focused on
Asia South America Central America
forming the relationships so that our
faculty can work with those that other
universities are perhaps work on
projects in other countries such as
China where we're looking at say
environmental impacts on health those
environmental impacts be much greater
than they are here in California
pollution being even that much worse and
so and also the health behavior effects
of things like smoking around the world
so we learn a lot from other countries
and and we hope that they learn from us
by coming here
thank you dr. Hitler what's the German
perspective on this yeah my university
has always been a very International
University already from the beginning so
we still have 25 percent of foreign
students already now for 100 years or
more so but the question I understand a
little bit differently
internationalization or globalization
I've
I think these are two different shoes
and internationalization is fine you're
open for people from from from the rest
of the world to come to your place but
how do you prepare your students your
your faculty for the new challenges of
the globalization that's a little bit
different and for this purpose we have
created in cards for a house of
competence this means to promote social
competences and other things for
students before they go abroad before
they go to industry that they are
prepared that the world is different
than at home even if they meet and and
have good friends from the international
community of the students going to a
different country is a different event
in your life and what's very important
is that we have a very very good
language school to prepare those
students in in very very many languages
and I think this is very very important
before you go into a different country
you have to learn this language and I
think English is fine but English is for
me something like a tool and if you go
to different country which is not
America or Britain or Australia then you
should also learn these basics of this
language and I think globalization has
something to do with learning the
difference of the cultures and very very
early and that's a purpose at my
university and that's what we understand
to prepare for globalization thank you
and finally doctoral Namie
we our budget comes from Japanese
government but we are very active for
example in ICT has a large number of the
joint research project under MOU memory
of understanding only in the last single
year we concluded 20 more use with
partners in Finland Hungary Thailand the
United States and so on the purpose of
the MOU is to establish and maintain the
mutually beneficial partnership through
exchange information in our research
field exchanging researchers and Corgan
organizing and supporting so we are this
is a one example but we we want to open
this
thank you
okay so what we just heard I think is
that between universities getting
students from all over the world is
something that's been increasing quite a
bit to making sure that students are
versed in cultures and languages of
different parts of the world to
universities going out and teaching in
far-flung places Africa and elsewhere
that the universities are definitely in
a global community and of course they're
also in a technical community as well
lots of Technology in fact not to steal
his thunder but dr. Wu and I were
talking before the meeting about how
none of his students will actually talk
to him anymore
but they're happy to text him questions
so the question I have and I think I'd
like you to focus on this in the spirit
of the New York Times article recently
that talked about how students go to
classes but they do it from their dorm
room on their computer and the question
is ultimately how will technology change
the mission of a research university
both in terms of how you teach but also
in terms of what you teach and I'll let
whoever feels motivated to start please
dr. Hitler yeah let me start if you take
their the question by the words you say
what how the mission will change I would
say the mission won't change at all the
mission is education research and
innovation and this will not change
whatever IT and other facilities will
open so you may adapt your teaching you
may adapt your research you may use
these opportunities for have better
research better education and better
innovation but the mission will not
change whether you will use this
facilities to become better and more
competitive thank you so I agree that
the mission of the university is not
going to change and that we do need to
serve society we need to create
knowledge and transfer that knowledge
but there is a
mentioned within university set one
thing we do within universities is
extraordinarily conservative that we
protect traditions and we have rituals
and so on and then the other side is
when we do our research we try to be
extraordinarily innovative innovative
many aspects of our university remain
quite conservative and sometimes the
conservative side of the university
inhibits the innovation and part of that
is the way we do research the question
had to do with education but the way we
do research is driven by a set of rules
that were created decades ago and
haven't really changed much in terms of
how we reward acknowledged
accomplishments typically rewarding and
knowledge accomplishment accomplishments
at an individual level and based on
products that are maybe not the best
ways to disseminate our research that we
created our rules based on printed
publications when that's maybe not the
dominant way that we innovate today so
universities need to adapt so that they
do remain at the forefront and you know
we're all working on it but we need to
do more cherry I can call Jerry by his
first name because we've met before you
can too this is a topic in fact that we
spent much of the afternoon discussing
and it's a very interesting and
important learn obviously very timely at
Carnegie Mellon this is an area of very
active research where we brought
together cognitive scientists or
computer scientists human-computer
interaction experts designers in
learning scientists to create what I
believe to be so far the best online
full course interactive learning
environments I like what the speaker
said he's absolutely right that the big
promise here of Technology in this
respect is to make education much more
interactive a real learning environment
I believe that
as I've told my colleagues earlier today
that the combination of these
technologies which are still rather
primitive it will become much more
powerful with the forces in society that
universities are facing we will see some
very substantial changes in the way we
do things I agree with President Hitler
that our mission I believe will stay the
same it's the way we do things those
forces in society I'm talking about
especially in America are a great
concern about the cost of higher
education and therefore the need for
productivity improvements great concern
about quality of education that is our
students really learning when we claim
that they're learning I don't think it's
an issue for Carnegie Mellon or USC
but it is at other universities and
thirdly access to education take those
three things and add to them the kinds
of technologies that are now emerging
and you've got a combination that I
think that will result in very
significant change finally I should say
as the New York Times article indicated
that you referred to it it has already
changed its routine now for universities
especially large universities to be
using these online technologies they're
not very good yet because they're not
using the kinds of things that we've
developed but they will be and finally
the largest university in America is a
University of Phoenix a for-profit
company with more than 200,000 students
and it's largely an online university so
the future is here this is not
hypothetical
it's not in the future it's here and as
one of our colleagues put it today I
think it was Alex who said when you're
uncertain about the future the best
thing you do is invent it it's up to us
to really seize it and make the most use
of it
dr. Wu so I'd like to make the theme
about tech that enhances interaction
since this is interact in education
rather than isolation but let me give
you a couple of concrete examples of the
sort of thing that I'm talking about and
many of you may have seen this New York
Times I think article last week about
students who no longer bother attending
lectures because they can just watch it
in the in the dorm and but the downsides
of that and the regrets that students
who who do that eventually count I think
it's important to remember that one of
the really important functions of a
university as that as a knowledge
management organization is the
unintended water-cooler effect types of
things
I mean universities classes force very
different students who don't like each
other or their mutual opinions to have
to be together and and that is actually
something which is important and in the
the Internet in general our IT has
actually enabled people to avoid those
people you know in km terms it's driven
a rapid acceleration toward isolated
communities of practice that share
interests and biases and opinions at the
expense of having to deal with those who
don't share that it has created
fragmentation the sort of polarization
sort of isolation of these communities
and that is a role that I think we on
the information technology side can
actually actively look at overcoming how
can we build technologies that have the
opposite effect
you know I in in teaching in the in
lecturing in the classrooms I've tried
an experiment the last couple of
semesters I don't use PowerPoint and I
don't give them notes and they scream
and they complain but like most of us
when we were young it forces them to
actually take notes which has been
proven to be a very good way to make
people actually think about what they're
hearing and internalize it and then what
happens
you try this have any of you tried this
what happens when you do this to the
students so now we have to find a way to
defeat that in in in Asia we are
confronting some particular unique
problems there Asian students really
don't like to answer questions they
don't like to speak in class they hate
it with a passion to the extent that
they lobby their classmates from
overseas to not answer so many of the
professor's questions because that will
just encourage him to ask more questions
on the other hand as mentioned earlier
they love instant messaging they love
texting they loved logs and too so I now
have them in class with their laptops
and stuff doing live blogging in class
so that they will ask questions just not
verbally but these are the things that
we can use technology we can embrace it
and find a way to pervert it to our own
interests of increasing the interaction
instead of isolating them in Hong Kong
especially we have problems with
language comprehension a lot of our
students have less than stellar English
comprehension abilities and yet all of
the lectures are in English they have to
be we have a lot of international
students so we're looking also
technologies that would enhance that
translation and so forth thank you dr.
Cherie
students to the late maybe or general we
should reduce the cost but we I think
there is a some way to diffuse the cost
we can use we should use for example we
if we consider the some small region
yes so I mean I think I mean I agree
that the mission of the university is
not probably not changing very much on
the other hand disciplines are evolving
faster than then then a few years ago
and also curricula are evolving faster
or should be evolving faster than a few
years ago so I think that where
technology could help is probably you
know to to remove let's say to reduce
direct interactions for for aspects of
teaching which do not really require
direct interaction and and and then
concentrate the work that we do with the
students only to the aspects which are
changing so fast or that are you know
changing one day after the other so that
we teach something which is up-to-date
and and and and and this I think is
where technology could could really
could really help to try to for us for
teachers to invest our times our time on
topics which are not established living
there the topics which are already
discussed and well established two more
you know technologically based tools and
one last comment dr. khatib well
actually I was going to give the example
of
haptics how haptics is changing the way
in fact we interact with the physical
world in the classroom in research as
one of the example of those new emerging
technologies robotics AI and other
fields are bringing so we used to to
just look at the screen to to to see the
results now we can interact and we can
in fact affect the behavior of what what
we are simulating this is in fact one
one little example of many of the
development that are enhancing the
experience of learning and in fact
bringing new dimensions to that
experience I just wanted to mention
another point in relation to technology
and research and education and that is
the connection with industry that is
well I probably Stanford has a history I
mean we are here in the Silicon Valley
and probably a large part of the reason
we have the Silicon Valley is it's
Berkeley and Stanford and the
universities were round here that really
brought most of the seats for many of
those companies Google guys were student
in our lab by the way I'm some equity in
the AI lab at Stanford in computer
science and I'm also a president of the
International Foundation of robotic
research of my research and work is
mostly in robotics but in in the
transfer of technology there is a lot of
dynamic that is taking place where in
fact
that interaction that is taking place
with the industry is guiding the ways
some of the research is promoted is
pushed is developed and we we see a lot
of examples of that in the medical
community where a lot of the research
that came out of robotics and went into
medical robotics was supported and
sponsored and and pushed somehow by the
industry so affiliate programs I have
been the director of the affiliate
program of Stanford computer science
department where we have 80 companies
all around the world involved in a lot
of interaction many companies in Japan
and Europe as well as here in the
Silicon Valley and all around the
country and that interaction is creating
all kind of new project new directions
pointing to the research in fact
promoting great thank you so the next
question which actually follows on to
what dr. khateeb is talking about is
written on my paper is what will be
possible when now I think if we were
actually you know trying to answer that
question we'd be here a long time so I'd
like to narrow it down and I'd really
like to narrow it down though I see we
have what someone who's willing to
answer that what will be possible when
but I'd like to also put it in the
context up if we think of education and
we think of how universities teach
things and collaboration between
universities and and industry sort of
how will technology what pieces of
technology will allow us to go change
how we how we teach and how students
learn go ahead so I'm shocked at
Stanford how backward a number of things
are at the school
SCPD for instance the continued
professional development
no interaction there on the other hand I
am amazed how the students when you give
them the chance to actually innovate
teaching how well they do I like dick I
am not using powerpoints anymore the
students write the notes in a wiki I
have done that for four or five years
now and I go myself to the notes the
students wrote if i refresh my memory
about certain facts so I think the
innovation is coming from bottom up and
not from the institution as far as
teaching goes and I should say I only
teach one class the year standard so I
think it's probably somewhat outside
perspective I'm providing the other
point of course is that education will
be revolutionized through the fast
feedback and duper device most of us
carry with us called the mobile phone
that I think learning happens if you get
feedback if you get feedback fast and we
are not even seeing the beginning of the
revolution of the mobile in education
what it means in the workplace in the
larger scheme is I think in atomization
that people will do those tasks they are
interested in and they will do the well
and we have you know more or less good
matching algorithms that pair me up and
have a certain task for somebody's
willing to do the task
so dr. Chen you come from a company that
sells a few mobile devices how do you
how do you respond okay so being from
Nokia I heartily agree with what Andrea
just said you know this is going to be
your main device they are five billion
mobile subscriptions worldwide and only
one point two billion pcs or a why so
there are lots of people with this
device over the world have never seen a
PC PC was invented here we impose it on
the rest of the world thinking that
keyboards are absolutely natural but
it's completely alien for a lot of
people but this device is being adopted
in different ways so this was really and
Moore's law will make sure that this
will be as powerful is of the PC we have
today but I want to make a couple other
observation on education I take a
bottom-up inductive approach I look at
my 14 year old daughter she's a
straight-a student I don't know how she
does it well actually this is what she
does when she has a homework assignment
she doesn't know how to answer a
question she simply cut and paste that
question and drop it into the Google
search box really this is how she does
it amazingly she gets an answer very
quick and if she doesn't get the answer
then then she puts it on her Facebook
page she's got over 150 friends usually
within minutes she gets the answer so
other than this mobile device there's
two other thing one is that learning or
education is going to involve these
rapid discovery of content in the cloud
as well as dynamic real-time learning
through social networks and community
collaboration this is what teenagers are
doing today I mean I was amazed the
first time I walked in her room and she
asked me a question saying dad do you
know this the answer to this question I
said I have no idea and she just cut
paste drop into Google boom usually on
the first page
she gets her answer so this is sort of
how you know things are evolving like
you decide whether or not that's evil
but know it this is very important I
think because I don't know that we'd
call that learning it's without question
that's what they do all of our kids do
it I'm sorry I didn't know the name of
the first person who commented I with
him completely the key here the real
game changer is feedback and the new
technologies including the open learning
initiative I refer to before a Carnegie
Mellon the real value of it is in the
real time assessment it provides on what
the student is learning
both to the student and the big game
changer to the instructor the feedback
is the key so if we're going to talk
about learning as opposed to simply
acquiring information sorry doctor
saying you haven't had a chance to speak
tonight yeah wanted to point out that a
lot of the challenges that with the
globalization of education the students
are facing as a corporate environment
you know where the company which is
present across 50 nations we sort of you
know go through
hello closer to the mic so we you know
we sort of go through similar paradigms
and similar challenges as well and I
think one of the key things is the
immersiveness of the experience so
whether it's you know telepresence or
any video conferencing facility that
really engages the audience I think it
lets you cut down on travel budget and
stuff of that sort now having said that
I don't think that's quite possible in
an academic setting where students don't
quite have the budget to you know for
that kind of infrastructure but we've
seen you know sort of innovation having
you know taught courses at Stanford as
well a lot of seminars now put on
YouTube or you know you have internal
websites where students can just access
it whether or not they're enrolled in a
particular course or not so I think that
outreach sort of lets us you know sort
of go to a broader set of community
leaders we have the add to that I think
the economics really paste the key role
there and prints all of my classes I
create a transcript or have the
transcript created and everybody in the
world without login can comment on that
and you just leverage by doing things
which would have been super expensive
before you leverage basic the world to
make your class better and in that
process for drugs and I think another
comment is that you know this open
innovation model that industries and
academic institutions are adhering to
could sort of you know expand to a more
open education model where more and more
lectures from the universities can put
output be put out in the open so even
then in you know it's an excellent
example which CMU is doing by sort of
you know expanding the presence globally
but if these lectures are available
openly and then places where we
not afford to have you know places set
up still students and people who are
interested can actually access all the
know-how which is generated from
academia great thank you I'm gonna give
you a chance I'm gonna let you will go
let you answer the next question because
it's going to lead on from this question
which is so we just heard from dr. Singh
about how there's a just a wealth of
information both from industry and
companies and from universities
available on the web and how that are
the lead to collaboration and so what
I'd like to go make this question is an
open-ended one as to how do we use some
of the technologies that we've been
talking about to go and improve and
increase collaboration both between
universities and also between
universities and industry I was just
going to mention an experience at
Stanford which is the d.school the
design school which is going beyond the
conventional way of Education thinking
about new dimensions in the process of
learning and it's social implication
it's real connection with with with the
society and and also the way we we are
delivering the the knowledge and the
experience itself for the students it is
is a new experience that started a few
years ago and I think it probably it's
one of the possible models for the
future dr. now how about collaboration
in Japan between either universities or
universities and industry as the key
task
factors the first is the integration of
worldwide indigent and the second is
education for children in international
environment the third one is technical
collaboration including joint research
and straightfoward
energy transfer and university industry
I support you you are well aware that
all these tasks difficult for individual
organization they cannot be achieved
without international thank you I'm
anyone else want to comment on
collaboration before I open it up to the
floor well I would just point out that
the that which brings us together today
interact
there's a wonderful example of
international inter-institutional
collaboration where many of the faculty
involved in this have been able to do
things that they could not have done it
would not have done had it not been for
the collaborative structures that have
been debated it's great thank you
okay anyone from the audience have a
question on globalization or technology
and universities or collaboration the
general rule I have is if you don't ask
questions that of the panel then I start
asking questions of you or pick someone
to go ask a question like you know Jim
Mitchell or someone who always has all
right he's going to ask
all right Jim's gonna volunteer to ask
the first question there's some mics in
the back or just talk loud
or companies working with universities
so the question kisser Montagnard is
Howard University's dealing with
intellectual property issues between the
University and the companies they want
to work with let me let me comment I
this is so having spent four years at
Nokia prior to that six years at Intel
prior to that 17 years of faculty at
Carnegie Mellon I think this is this is
really a critical key issue we need to
really rethink this whole model because
if you look at all the universities what
they have invested in in terms of
building their patenting department and
this licensing return that they get it's
a net negative it's a net negative
except for a few patents you know from
Stanford and biotech area and a handful
others like the past advisers and
patents formulas of Wisconsin except for
a handful of them it's really a
money-losing game and I think we just
need to we need to just really have some
common sense here and most companies are
not trying to exploit this creative
faculty members ideas they're actually
for big companies it's a defensive thing
they just want to make sure that when
they fund research it doesn't lead to a
patent that holds them hostage later and
so they're you know so we need to look
at the big picture look at the numbers
and let's find a new way where we can
collaborate where it yes
created faculty member of the campus our
core idea should somehow be compensated
but it's not through these you know
litigation because these big companies
they will pay off because there are no
it they're no lose-lose situation
because if they win to fight in court
there
review as beating on this this creative
professor so I think we need a we need
this is a big topic that I think we need
to really rethink and there needs to be
a new model in order to sustain this
kind of open innovation we always like
to talk about but usually it's this this
one issue is frequently that the
stumbling block so this sounds like it
needs a university a response because I
think what I just heard was university
shouldn't be filing patents I'm
wondering in but no he didn't say that
no okay let me try I try to or do go
ahead dr. Shalini okay well I have a
Willa Kerry talk first
well good University response first
moderators privilege here
of course one can't generalize about all
universities each institution is
different and no doubt some have pursued
their approach intellectual property
with the idea of maximizing revenue in
mind and I know you probably won't
believe this but in fact we are greatly
constrained by federal law both with
regard to who owns the intellectual
property and what kind of licensing
arrangements were allowed to give in
advance I agree with you completely that
this is a problem in fact it's a
national crisis and it needs to be
changed but it's all going to be changed
as the law gets changed until it does we
really are constrain about about what we
can do so I can elaborate on that if you
want but I don't think you want me to
okay all right good doctor did you want
to make one yes I mean fully agree and
in fact at Stanford we are I mean moving
in a direction where collaboration can
bring about sharing intellectual
property and this is within the
framework of collaboration between
academia and the industry and there is a
new office that
is handling those kind of agreements in
fact there are a lot of agreement that
are made today between different groups
faculty and companies involving shared
intellectual properties
the basic principle at Stanford
University and many other university was
that you cannot buy intellectual
property so it's not by just funding a
project we can acquire the intellectual
properties however there are shared
ideas and discussions that involve other
alternate that in those projects and
that can be part of why we will be
sharing so the development officer at
Stanford University is working on ok
just to follow up comment to that you
know so in my experience I've seen a lot
of diversity across Europe and us so you
know those telecom we've invested in you
know Germany in some universities and
also in Israel there the IPR agreements
are much more you know in favor of the
industry in the respect that you can
gain back the IP ours at Stanford
however you know just like we discussed
there's a there's a different paradigm
but what we've sort of figured out is
that in a more open innovation model
there's a lot that the industry can gain
because usually the consortium you know
for our case the consortiums that we
found that they comprise multiple
industries you know whether these are
vendors or service providers or hardware
manufacturers they all sort of pool in
their intellect and know-how and
although we've invested in the open
innovation model that lets us sort of
harness which was much more than what
was initially invested in so we've sort
of you know try to figure out figure out
ways of working around the things dr.
Hippler
yeah I I think there's a big difference
particularly between the US and Europe
and and Germany and also I think there's
a difference between private university
and public universities and for us in
Germany mostly public universities I
think our mission is to
transfer money into knowledge and the
mission of industry is to transfer a
knowledge into money and this interface
is the most important interface and how
to deal with this interface depends on
the laws you have in your States on your
countries and therefore the situation is
very very different in in in in the
world and it's it's not easy to handle
so what for my university the laws and
forces to do this and to to have this
own service unit for treating with
intellectual properties and patterns and
licenses but for us it's really really a
red number and there's nothing coming
out and it takes four ages and if you
have a cash cow this is very very rare
and the question is whether it's
worthwhile to have your efforts in this
as a public university to do so I think
it's not and there are better ways to
deal with industry and I think what's
very very important is a kind of
confidence between industry and under
and the university how to deal with
these kind of things and then in the
future this may develop much much better
than for having certain rules
alright more questions from the audience
okay so the question was how do you see
sites like Wikipedia on the quality of
information and the information people
trust and apparently the answers your
students give to tests so I'm surprised
that people emphasize information again
and again here I think universities are
not about transmitting information at
least not now you can find that the
risks are about helping people ask the
right questions lures are about helping
people make the right decisions
understanding trade-offs of these
decisions yes we do need data we need
information for that but so that's my
perspective that maybe you should
rethink as we all have Wikipedia our
fingertips what it is that we ever
should be doing you mentioned mr. st.
Vincent other times before actually I'm
not familiar with them but I think it
might be time to reflect in this very
different world in terms of
globalization in terms technology to
think what we should be giving our
students okay one else one answer that
yeah I I completely agree I think it is
not about the answer I really don't care
that the answer is right I really want
to see the process of thinking the
ability to come up with new questions
and answer other new problems in
independently and that process is not
going to be just learned by finding the
answer somewhere so this is this is very
important in education and that process
is very important dr. Hall the key one
yeah so part of what we teach our
students is how to discriminate between
authentic and valid information versus
something that might be biased or
something might be fabricated or are
just not true and a traditional way that
we operate within universities is is the
peer review process so essentially you
find experts experts review it they say
whether it's good or bad they provide
comments and that leads to something
that in a way is certified as as
authentic Wikipedia doesn't exactly
work that way but it is created within a
community and it does have a way of
validation associated with it because
people have opportunity to make changes
to it and corrections and comments and
so forth I think we're evolving to a
different world where what is valid and
not valid is determined by different
means that in the past and I think that
does make it a new challenge for the
students as well as the faculty is how
to discriminate and you know many cases
Wikipedia is more accurate than things
that maybe validated through peer review
processes and we have to figure out in
the future how to do that ok ok one last
question Martin to give a question
so I think the question is basically
with all this information available out
on the Internet
how do we improve how we teach how do we
get students to ask better questions dr.
Sydney would you like - I think it is
it's it's very big problem in some sense
because we need to change the way we
evaluate students you know and and and
in some sense we need to change ways you
know we evaluate our surface teachers
and I mean I personally don't have an
answer to this we need it's the only
thing that is that I can say is that we
have to go away from you know teaching
from the from a desk you know and move
toward doing research together or doing
activities together so again is is the
issue of investing our time in
activities which really requires our
intervention you know leaving aside all
the activities that can be you know all
the teaching that that can be thought by
question and answer and you know in that
respect I work on the robotics and in
that respect I think robots are really
very very interesting teaching tools
because you can teach using robots you
can teach a lot of different disciplines
and with with and so on and you know you
can go in-depth into that ok it's
getting late so what we're gonna do is
thank you very much - panelists
you